foreign
[Music]
you think your wife can hear you
no
white ball
Maybe I'm Wrong
to die
maybe not goodbye to you my trusted
friend
a new day is Dawning
new ideas no wounds
New Management we've been
since we
who is this
challenge him to single combat with a
loose it's a way out
I don't sit at the table your family
does please pray for me
[Music]
man has to look his best when it's time
to get married
or buried I'm going to need a gun
goodbye my friend
[Music]
if you win
the table will honor its word
we'll have your freedom
under the old laws only one can survive
failure to meet at sunrise
for result in execution
Last Words Winston just have fun out
there
I want you to find your peace but the
good death only comes after good life
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend
let's go
[Music]
have you given any thought to where this
ends
the table will never stop
you know this
no one
not even you
can kill everyone
foreign
you ready John
[Music]
the John Wick series is known for its
cool and deadly characters so what can
we look forward to in John Wick chapter
four let's take a moment to talk about
the cast of the film and the old as well
as the new characters
first and foremost of course there is
Jonathan John Wick himself arguably the
world's most popular killer continues to
be played by one of the world's most
popular actors that being Keanu Reeves
there is nothing but love for the
friendly neighborhood assassin as he did
not start the Bloodshed himself but
merely took revenge for his sweet dog
and let's be honest who Among Us
wouldn't do the same for their
four-legged friend so far he's killed no
less than 306 people in the first three
movies leaving most of the other Killers
far behind well maybe with the exception
of Marvel's Thanos but our anti-hero has
of course not survived entirely
unscathed be it shot stabbed in the
stomach injured by bottles or thrown out
of a building in the end he always
managed to stand up again fix is always
well fitted suit and look for his next
Target
as John's first ex-companion we have to
deal with Winston played by Ian McShane
the latter turned on him at the end of
chapter 3 and shot him several times
until he fell off the Continental this
brought the Continental back to its old
status and Winston back to his old job
whether he intended to kill him or was
aware that he would survive it is not
really clear at the end but after the
adjudicator leaves Winston seems to be
smiling and says Baba Yaga this suggests
that he may know exactly what happened
to Jon who just barely survived the fall
and was taken to the Bowery kick and
this is who we will deal with next the
Bowery King is played by Lawrence
Fishburne which surely put some Smiles
on the faces of many Matrix fans back
then seeing Neo and Morpheus face each
other again after such a long time in a
completely different world his real name
is not known and may remained a secret
forever the Bowery King Compares Jon's
injuries to his own and asks him whether
he's angry with the high table after Jon
answers in the affirmative he reveals
that he will wage a war against the high
table for wrongfully punishing him and
killing his men Jon makes it clear that
he intends to join his war and thus the
groundwork for chapter 4 is laid a
little side fact the name Bowery King is
an allusion to the Middle Ages
apparently there used to be bigger Kings
who got information from vagrants and
homeless people and sold it on similar
to what Lord Varys did in Game of
Thrones finally of course we can't do
without Lance Reddick as Chara he is the
concierge of the hotel in Winston's
right-hand man he takes care of all
kinds of tasks in the hotel and also
offers John all sorts of services for
example taking care of his dog or
shooting people down if he has to
in each part there are also all sorts of
new bounty hunters who were out to get
John this is of course also the case in
John Wick 4. thereby we will also see
some faces which we know from other
martial arts movies let's start with the
Lesser known names first we have Rina
sawyama in the role of Akira sawyama is
mostly known for being a singer and a
model she has made the occasional
appearance on late night shows however
John Wick 4 will be her very first film
then Scott Adkins is best known from
many second tier action movies and will
play a character named Killa here the
British actor and martial artist works
not only as an actor but also as a
stuntman since 1998 he has participated
in about 60 Productions the most famous
among them should be The Expendables 2
Dr Strange and Ip Man 4 as the third
newcomer we have shamier Anderson called
tracker in the film The 31 year old has
been acting in rather small productions
for 10 years therefore the film may also
serve as a stepping stone for him
another martial arts artist signed on is
Marco zaroor in the role of Chidi in
addition to his own acting roles he has
often worked as a stunt double for
Dwayne The Rock Johnson these were the
four less known faces in the movie now
let's move on to the old hands first we
have the young Swede Bill Skarsgard he
will play a character called Marquis his
probably biggest role was the clown
Pennywise in it there was also part of
Marvel's eternals and with hiroyuki
Sonata the filmmakers were able to
secure one of the best known Japanese
actors in John Wick chapter 4. he will
slip into the role of shimazu whether
it's bullet train Mortal Kombat endgame
or the Wolverine Sonata has appeared in
all kinds of major Productions over the
past 20 years either as a sidekick or as
an antagonist with Donnie Yen The
Producers were able to bring in another
star from the East the Ip Man star plays
a bounty hunter named Kane Yen gained
great notoriety in the past 10 years
primarily in the role of Wing Chun
Master Ip Man and of course in Rogue one
a Star Wars story as the fighting monk
charit imway due to his achievements in
recent years in 27 17 he was even
admitted to the academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences the
organization that annually Awards the
Oscars the final well-known actress we
have is Natalia Tena in the role of
Katya most of you will know tenna for
playing The Ore nymphadora Tonks from
Harry Potter her last major television
role was in the Mandalorian in 2019. we
still have one big name for you but a
role name in the film is not yet known
Clancy Brown will also be involved in
the film the 1.92 meter tall giant
became known in the role of kurgan in
Highlander from 1986. since then he has
participated in well over 200
Productions as an actor or voice actor
his last role was in the rather unknown
movie Last looks in 2021
as always as long as the filmmakers
remain silent it is not that easy to
talk about the plot at least Keanu
Reeves himself presented the first
teaser trailer for the movie at the
Comic-Con in San Diego besides a lot of
action the trailer shows Jon training
hard for his Vendetta with a Bowery King
at the end the king of the homeless even
shows up with a fresh suit and asks John
whether he's ready anyhow it's clear
that the two will be hunting down the
high table in its 12 bosses from the
looks of the trailer these will include
Clancy Brown and scarsgard's character
another interesting aspect will be the
roles of Winston and Sharon both have
obviously turned against Jon but whether
they really still work for the high
table is unclear after all the latter
would have sacrificed the continental
and Winston without batting an eye it
will also be particularly exciting to
delve deeper into the character of the
Bowery King and his Empire or rather
what is left of it for one thing should
be clear he and John can only move in
the shadows now in the trailer Akira
tracker and shimazu seem to be on Jon's
side mainly because Jon and shimasu
fight together against Donnie and as
Kane wither works for or with Marquis
about the other newcomers unfortunately
no information is known yet director
Chad stachelski also spoke a bit about
the plot in the end of the film in an
interview he emphasized that the fourth
film will definitely end on a very
emotional level we'll also bring some
storylines to a close this does not mean
that it will be the final part since in
addition to a fifth film a prequel is
also being planned in the form of the
miniseries the Continental we hope to
find out more about the plot soon one
thing is for sure though there will
surely be no lack of action
the new movie was already confirmed back
in May 2019 and Chad stachelski will
once again take up his position in the
director's chair incidentally he was
Keanu Reeves's stunt double in the first
Matrix film and was recently allowed to
be beaten up by Trinity in part 4 of the
Sci-Fi series as the unpleasant husband
Chad thus both the director and the lead
actor share a friendship that has lasted
for years and we think that shows in the
John Wick Series in December 2019 Reeves
began gun food training in preparation
for filming both the fourth John Wick
movie and Matrix resurrections a preview
of his progress could already be seen in
the trailer there was a sequence with
Donnie Yen in which the two of them
showed off the combination of
hand-to-hand combat and Firearms after a
long period of delay shooting them again
on June 28 2021 at Studio babel'sburg in
Potsdam as well as in Berlin and Paris a
mere five months later filming was
officially concluded it is also known
that a fifth part is already being
worked upon Lionsgate CEO John
feldheimer announced that the script has
already been in development since August
20 20 stahlski by the way told The
Hollywood Reporter his secret for the
series success he claimed that John Wick
simply has to be made to suffer in the
interview he stated we keep finding new
and interesting ways to have John Wick
suffer that's where the action comes
from figure out how to make him suffer
and then design backward in retrospect
this is a very smart approach
alright that was all the latest news
about the fourth part of John Wick which
new actor are you looking forward to the
most and how do you think the whole
movie will end let us know in the
comment section and if you like this
video please feel free to give it a
thumbs up see you next time
thank you